welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar comprehensive and
tracked fusion detection agnostic of a
fusion partner for optimal
identification of rare genomic events it
is presented by Philip Sabo MD chief
medical officer at Illumina and mode
champagne who is in Clinical Oncology
marketing at Illumina my name is to do
Roark and I will be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Illumina for more information about our
sponsor visit WWE for we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speakers will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentations if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
tab located in the top right corner of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. Philip Zeebo and mode
champagne I will now turn the
presentation over to them
thank you Judy and welcome everyone for
today's presentation and I'm excited to
talk to you about approaches to
detecting fusion and specifically novel
fusion partners increasingly identifying
fusions that can be targeted by drugs
it's becoming part of oncology and
important for oncologists to understand
my part today
will be broken down into three specific
topics the first is the role and
importance of comprehensive kinase
fusion detection we'll go over some data
that supports by previous statement to
we'll go over the best methodology for
comprehensive kinase fusion detection
what are the methods currently used what
are their benefits what are their
challenges finally we'll go over
comprehensive genomic profiling for rare
kinase fusion detection
so let's start with the first part and
that is really the importance of
identifying kinase fusions in tumors for
your patients it's important to start
with what is a fusion this is very basic
but a fusion is basically when one part
of a chromosome
exchanges locations with another part of
a different chromosomes this can also
occur within chromosomes but the diagram
here shows it's simply an exchange an
equal exchange of genomic material
between locations what happens with that
exchange is oftentimes two genes that
are often in different locations are now
placed adjacent to each other
fortunately we do see common fusions
about 35% of all fusions are recurrent
and known this diagram demonstrates what
happens when those fusions occur so in
this cartoon you see one gene in blue
one gene in purple and the fusion the
translocation of the chromosomal
segments bring the two genes together so
that there is a five-prime partner and a
3 prime partner oftentimes with most of
the fusions we're talking about today
the five prime partner is largely acting
as a promoter largely these are genes
that are oftentimes expressed at high
levels in the specific tissue type from
in which the camp from which the cancers
derived and the three prime partner the
kinase des moines is an active element
of the protein oftentimes a kinase that
elicits a signaling antigenic signaling
that drives tumor development growth
proliferation and occasionally
metastasis
so this novel fusion creates a
combination where this kinase is now
oftentimes expressed at very high levels
or at least expressed in an
inappropriate context where it has an
effect on
cancer development and cancer
progression
so now that we know that fusions what
fusions are and how the 5-prime promoter
when combined with a target kinase
increases expression how common is it in
metastatic disease this paper from
Memorial sloan-kettering and their
clinical testing that they perform
looked at 10,000 patients and they found
that 15 percent of patients with
metastatic disease had fusions within
their genomes these fusions were
associated and driving the expression of
genes that are known to be involved in
tumor Genesis and also can be targets
for treatment when another group looked
at the TCGA samples these are samples
from across different types of cancer
been a very large effort over the past
decade to molecularly characterize a
large number of tumors of the common and
less common tumors and these
investigators ask the question what
proportion of each type of tumor had
fusions this diagram shows you the range
with which fusions where identified up
at the top you see prostate
adenocarcinoma with a high frequency of
a specific fusion and then throughout
the other types of cancer you see
different proportions that contain
fusions
in fact when they looked at these
fusions in aggregate 6% of the fusions
identified could be targeted with drugs
that were available again showing that
it's very important to identify these
fusions for your patients that these
fusions can be detected across a range
of different types of tumors and that
when fusions are identified a certain
proportion are targetable with drugs
that are available
now each fusion can have different
partners
so each kinase that's involved in a few
can have different partners and here
we're going to talk about alq
fusions because alkanes are probably the
first and most widely known fusion where
there are alkene hibbott errs that have
had a major impact in patients with lung
cancer who have those fusions and has
dramatically improved the outcomes of
those patients when a tumor with an out
fusion is targeted with an elk inhibitor
so we talked about out fusions focusing
on elk and but the truth is there are
multiple five prime partners with out
that are driving the expression of elk
and driving the dependence of that tumor
on elk
EML for in bold in the upper panel on
the right is the most common and often
the example that people have in mind
when they think about an Alcon but you
can see other fusion partners that have
been associated with alq
and each of those partners drive the
expression of alq and can be targeted
without inhibitors with good effect as
we've seen more and more recurring
fusions we've seen similarly that other
fusions that can also be targeted have
multiple upstream partners so ret which
is being recognized as a targetable
kinase has been found to have 30
different v prime partners in track and
there are three end track teams one two
and three have is more promiscuous with
61 different upstream partners of N Trek
driving the expression of n track 1 2 or
3 and then P GF R alpha P gr for beta
you can get a sense that even though
these kinases are starting to be seen as
recurrent specific kinases that can be
targeted the upstream drivers
partners of the fusions can be quite
different and diverse we'll drive into
that a little bit again looking at TCGA
data another group asked specific
questions about the frequency of fusions
and how common it is to find fusions
with the same two genes so some of these
numbers are pretty impressive so 50% of
recurrent kinase fusions
so those kinase fusions that were found
in two or more tumors in the TCGA data
included a new kinase partner so a new
partner for that kinase that had not
previously been identified so you don't
always know what you're looking for when
you need to identify a fusion 8% of the
recurrent fusions found in a tumor type
had not been previously described in
that tumor type so
if you were only looking for what you
knew you wouldn't even have looked for
that fusion in that tumor type and 11
percent of recurrent fusions are novel
they had not been seen before and this
continues to be the case the more tumors
that are comprehensively sequenced and
sequenced in a way where you can
identify novel fusions the more fusions
we are starting to see and understand if
we bring this back to n track this is a
diagram that shows different v3 and
track genes and the different partners
that have found been found on the
5-prime promoter region driving and
track inhibition so you can see in track
one has been found with the most number
of v prime partners but both n track 2
and track 3 both have multiple sometimes
they share a partner such as sqs TM 1 in
the middle you can see that has been
found associated and driving the
expression of each of the 3 n track
genes and the colors of the of in this
diagram represent the different tumor
types so you can also get a sense for
that these n track fusions have
different partners and they can be found
across a broad range of tumor types
the importance of identifying this these
fusions has to do with the remarkable
impact that successfully targeting the
fusions has on patient outcomes Alcon
hibbott errs are probably the most
widely used in lung cancer to target
fusions involving alq
here we just call attention to al Senza
as a drug that can target out regardless
of its fusion partner and has been shown
to improve outcomes that story is
primarily in lung cancer remarkably in
2018 we Trek V has been approved for
patients with n Trek fusions this is
regardless of the upstream partner for n
track and it's regardless of the
specific and Trek genes could be in
track one two or three and it's also
regardless of the tumor type the tech
free approval is the first approval for
a drug targeting a fusion that is
agnostic of the type of tumor so it
doesn't require it being in lung cancer
it can be in a broad array of cancers as
long as you identify the patient's tumor
as having an N track fusion they are
eligible for photography and the study
suggests that they benefit and of course
we've already gone over we know n track
can have many fusion partners and 61
have been identified to date
so now that we've gone over fusions
let's talk about how to detect them
so as we think about comprehensive
kinase fusion detection there are
multiple methodologies - tech fusion in
place already
there's fish analysis or fluorescence in
situ hybridization THC immunity's -
chemistry you can use PCR you can use
next-generation sequencing and with
next-generation sequencing there are
different approaches - there's the
amplicon based approaches and hybrid
capture based approaches and finally you
can either start looking at DNA isolated
from tumors or you can look at RNA
isolated from tumors fishes perhaps the
most widely used method to identify
complex rearrangements and specifically
is used for al cross one and ret in a
study by Memorial Sloan Kettering they
looked at samples that were tested using
fish and they also performed foundation
1 a comprehensive genomic testing to
assess for the presence of fusions 26%
of patients were found to have fusions
by fish and were where therapies were
available but 39% 12 of 31 patients were
found to have a fusion bye-bye next
generation sequencing alone within these
fish break apart probes had missed two
alkanes - ret fusions and one ross one
rearrangement which all of which have
approved therapies for and all of which
you would not want to miss if you're
taking care of patients with those
tumors and 6% of the tumors an
alteration was found for which there was
not a targetable not a not a drug and
then no genomic alteration was found in
29% so while fish is often used and is
perhaps most often use
this study demonstrates that you can
miss targetable fusions if you rely only
on fish and this gets even more
difficult as you consider some of the
more promiscuous fusions so part of
understanding and developing a fish
assay involves knowing the probes in
this case for n track that we spoke
about earlier given the promiscuous
nature of n track and given that there
are three specific genes that can be
involved each to get a robust fish assay
you would need at least three different
tests and potentially more which given
the limitations of tissue and given the
number of additional fusions you want to
check for just becomes almost untenable
as the catalog of fusions increases to
keep fish as your method of analysis and
remain comprehensive so the benefits of
using single gene tests like fish and
including IHC so as we discussed
oftentimes these fusion partners lead to
a rearrangement and the overexpression
or inappropriate expression of a
specific gene you could take an approach
to saying well if I know what the target
of the fusions are and I know what I can
drug I can look at expression well
immunohistochemistry requires that you
find a strong antibody that can detect
the protein and robustly detect the
protein the advantages it's fast it's a
quick turnaround time and it's low cost
the challenge is that with each
additional fusion partner that we
identify in each targetable fusion
partner that we identify you need to
develop and validate another assay and
run it on samples so that it becomes
again increasingly difficult as our
log effusions is grown to stay focused
on assays that look at specific genes
rt-pcr is a way that you can start to
look for multiple partners using a
technology again there's a lot of
advantages to PCR with respect to speed
with respect to turnaround time with
respect to cost reverse transcription
PCR are rt-pcr starts with the RNA
creates DNA and then you design probes
that can capture either side either
partner of the fusion and will only
amplify a product and only detect an
amplified product win the fusions
presence so you can anticipate with this
technology you can come up with multiple
probe pairs that capture the fusions
that you know but you do have to know
the fusion partners because in order to
get amplification you need both a five
prime and the three prime probe that
will anneal to the appropriate target
and start the amplification process for
detection thus the challenges occur with
fusions that have novel partners or
unknown fusions that you will miss and
not be able to detect
next generation sequencing is an
emerging method that is being applied to
fusion detection as we discussed
there's amplicon based next-generation
sequencing and hybrid capture or
enrichment based
next generation sequencing amplicon
based is similar to the approach that
was just that I just described with PCR
where you take probes for specific
regions and you amplify up segments of
DNA in order to
have sufficient copies to perform robust
sequencing and get the sequence of the
amplified products again it's this
requires an approach where you
understand
the regions that you are targeting to
amplify so oftentimes is most frequently
applied to areas where there are
specific mutations that are recurrent
some of the for example the activating
mutation seen in EGFR where you can
design probes to cover the region where
these mutations occur and you can then
sequence those amplified products to see
if the tumor has a specific mutation in
that area but as we discussed with
fusions as you have different partners
and as you're not if you don't know what
the fusion partners are it becomes
difficult if not impossible to design
the probes such that you get an
amplified product that you can sequence
and that limits the comprehensive
detection of fusions alternatively
hybrid capture includes creating probes
for the gene or genes of interest
regardless of adjacent material and
pulling them down and then sequencing
you so all you have to do is know that
you're interested in a specific gene if
you pull that gene down regardless
whether it's in a unaffected and in its
native state or whether it's affected
with a translocation and a fusion you
will still pull it down and sequencing
and when you sequence it you will
capture the information adjacent to it
which could include a fusion if it's
possible so the hybrid capture has
advantages in that you do have to know
the gene of interest the kinase of
interest and we know all the kinases
that are there and they are included in
most of the comprehensive genomic
profiling that occurs you do have to
know those genes but you don't have to
be aware of potential fusion partners
that are adjacent to that kinase of
interest in order to capture that this
figure diagrams some of the differences
so amplicon if we take e.t v6 and n
track 3 if you know both partners of the
fusion and you can design those probes
you can get amplified signal you'll
sequence that and you'll detect the
fusion with a novel fusion in this case
BTB be one with n track 3 you wouldn't
have a primer on that 5 prime partner of
n track 3 and you would not detect it if
you look at the hybrid capture approach
you can design probes that specifically
overlap for fusion events and pull them
down specifically but as long as you
have probes that target specific kinase
is like in track 3 will still pull down
and still be able to sequence and
identify that upstream 5 prime partner
that is novel that's the advantage of
hybrid capture over amplicon when it
comes to specific fusion detection
so hybrid capture
does decrease the risk the the need to
identify the 5-prime upstream partner
but when we think about fusions most of
the times we're thinking about the
effect of the protein that's created
where the end the RNA that's created
where the upstream promoter is driving
the kinase expression added DNA level
these regions can still be far apart and
interspersed with introns so these large
intronic regions specifically that have
been observed in and track 1 2 & 3 can
still challenge the hybridization
approach if you pull down one area of
end track the subsequent fusion may be
too far away to be captured within a
sequencing the sequencing run so one
approach to limit that challenge is to
look at RNA where RNA and starting with
RNA and the specifically we processed
mRNA brings the two partners closer
together by removing the intron material
and you can pull that down more
efficiently and capture that intron in a
sequencing reaction so as you think
about comprehensive kinase fusion
detection you have to think about what
your goals are for testing that patient
and if your goals are to comprehensively
assess for fusions and you want to allow
for the detection of novel fusions
and you want to overcome the challenges
of large intronic spaces that can
disrupt the ability to sequence the the
fusion and the association between two
genes five prime partner and the target
gene then you need to it's pretty clear
you walk down to next-generation
sequencing being a solution hybrid
capture having it
is over and pecan and hybrid capture
applied to material from tumour RNA
having advantages over applying it to
material from tumor DNA
okay so now we're going to go into the
third part of our discussion today and
that's comprehensive genomic profiling
for rare kinase fusion detection as I
mentioned earlier in November 2018 the
FDA approved the trek fee or allow
attractive as the first-ever trek
inhibitor for patients with advanced
solid tumors harboring the enteric gene
fusions the important and novel element
of this approval is that this is the
first time that a drug was received its
first approval for what we would term a
pan-cancer indication meaning it doesn't
matter what type of cancer the patient
has as long as they have an N Trek gene
fusion with either n track 1 2 or 3 and
regardless of the upstream 5 prime
partner they are eligible for this
treatment B and we'll go over this a
little bit and some data about the end
what happens when you target patients
with n track but from the studies that
led to the approval there was a 75%
overall response rate for patients when
treated with Lara trek demit who had N
Trek gene fusions and that was across
adult and pediatric cancers
so
the clinical studies for interaction and
the studies that led to the approval
found n track fusions over 19 different
tumor types it was found in both adult
and pediatric cancers and it was found
in to up to 1% of solid tumors so almost
any patient that has advanced disease
has the potential of harboring an N
track fusion within their tumor there
are some rare types of diseases rare
types of tumors where the frequency of n
track fusions was over 90% and but in
others and some of the more common tumor
types the frequency was about 5% so
understanding the distribution of n
track and the probability of any patient
having n track is important to
understanding what test is required the
good news is that oncology is
progressively moving more towards
comprehensive testing it certainly has
evolved over the past 20 years where
initially we started finding specific
single genes and enriching that and the
presence of amplifications or
overexpression would be associated to
with benefit from specific therapies
with her to being a one of the the first
that really the the the benefit of
therapy of the her2 targeting therapy
was dependent on identifying
overexpression for or amplification of
her to in breast cancer those different
targetable events stacked up we saw EGFR
we saw b-raf we saw an increasing number
of variants that when detected would
could be targeted and could identify
patients who specifically benefited from
targeted therapies
and we're oncology's moving is to
getting to a critical number of those
variants where it no longer makes sense
to test the variants one at a time and
it makes more sense to do a panel
sometimes targeted panels but more and
more moving to comprehensive panels and
what's driving towards those
comprehensive panels and it has a lot to
do with events like N Trek fusion
partners like Microsoft or MSI where
increasingly there are variants that
have shown to have value and to be
targetable regardless of the disease of
interest so that's an important part of
this the comprehensive genomic profiling
here's a definition that comes from CMS
and it is basically defined as a single
test using tumor tissue only not match
tumor normal that does not distinguish
between somatic and germline alterations
and can detect the following classes of
alterations so base pair substitutions
insertions and deletions those have been
an incredibly important for activating
different oncogenes like EGFR like b raf
like a large number of others that were
increasingly targeted but as we've
talked about also copy number variation
and homologous homozygous deletions as
well as the translocations or the
fusions that we've been talking about
today a comprehensive genomic profiling
and these rigorous tests can identify
each of these types of variants within a
tumor sometimes using the DNA to
identify those variants sometimes using
the RNA to identify the variants
of course it's important to consider is
comprehensive genomic profiling too much
are we you know using a sledgehammer to
hit a finishing nail and I would argue
at this point it's not the reason is
that many of these cancers for which we
want to understand the molecular
events that are driving that cancer have
rather limited tissue in some cases as
many as 30 percent of patients with lung
cancer do not have sufficient tissue for
more than a few tests and if you go by
single tests you exhaust the tissue
quite rapidly so comprehensive genomic
profiling helps minimize the burden on
tissue it can turn improve turnaround
time rather than serially testing one
gene at a time and if it's negative
going on to the next that that prolongs
the diagnostic Odyssey and Pro can
prolong the time that it takes to get a
patient on an effective therapy and all
that can translate into a cost savings
where you're efficiently testing for the
broad genomic events that can be
targeted and can by targeting can
improve outcomes without causing undue
delay or incremental cost
well when compared one-to-one the cost
of comprehensive genomic profiling may
be more expensive than a single test if
you add up the number of individual
tests it's very quick do you get to a
cost that's actually more than the
comprehensive genomic profiling itself
and this is becoming standard of care in
National Comprehensive Cancer Network in
their guidelines for non-small-cell lung
cancer they actually are recommending
the comprehensive testing in this case
broad molecular profiling is the wording
that you're using and they specifically
call out that this is important because
to minimize the wasting of tissue
because many of these lung cancer
patients do have tissue that's
inadequate for that just there's not
enough tissue to do a large number of
sequential testing and broad molecular
profiling so you want to spare it if you
want to get the broad molecular
but you do want to have the opportunity
to identify those fusions like n Trek
fusions and this is a diagram you may
have seen before it is from the study
supporting the approval of Lara Trek
timid or for as for paying cancer
indication this is a waterfall plot it
shows patients best response to therapy
with respect to measuring measurable
disease the different colors are
different types of tumors and every
patient treated has an end tract in
their tumor and this is what contributed
to the seventy-five percent objective
response rate and incredible incredible
responses across diseases some of which
have been are very difficult to treat
with conventional therapies such as
chemotherapy so this as well as many
other studies have frequently
demonstrated that although rare when
detected and targeted fusions can have
an incredible impact on that patients
outcomes because so often these fusions
are in our key drivers to the disease
and when targeted the disease has a
remarkable effect - and a response let's
talk a little bit about a single case of
a thirteen year old girl
she was diagnosed with a sarcoma and
quite frankly the sarcoma was you know
putting it her in harm's way he was
wrapped around her aorta and it was
removed through a high-risk surgery but
like many sarcomas had already spread
and next showed up in her spine
next-generation sequencing was performed
and a n track to fusion was detected and
apropos our earlier discussion it was in
fact the novel fusion with the str ng
she received our trek Deneb and the
tumors had a complete response to that
therapy so again here's a she's now a 14
year old freshman in high school and
having had a great response and more and
more the future of oncology is finding
molecular events in a tumor that are
drivers that can be targeted with a drug
and having outstanding responses like
what we see with Brianna in this example
so in conclusion
we've talked a lot about fusions about
novel fusions about how fusions can be
found in a broader range of cancers and
that identifying those novel fusions can
lead to targeted therapy and that
outstanding responses so
hopefully today's discussion makes all
of us really excited to identify these
fusions and not want to miss a single
patient and provide opportunities like
Lara trekked and it has if you're able
to identify an end track Fusion
hopefully you also now understand that
while you have a workflow and using RNA
to comprehensively assess for fusions
like end tract having the same assay
look at DNA and identify other variants
that can be targeted helps preserve
tissue and ensure that you get to a
timely diagnosis as soon as possible
finally you're really taking a
comprehensive assay and applying it to
your patient with different types of
cancer allows you to identify these
pan-cancer variants like and Trek
fusions like microsatellite instability
where the patient will benefit
regardless of the type of cancer they
have so we've spent a lot of time today
going over a comprehensive review of
different approaches to cancer and to
detect the different types of variants
that I incur with the goal that every
patient has the opportunity to fully
benefit from a growing list of targeted
therapies specifically including those
therapies that target kinases that are
part of fusion and then can have a
dramatic impact on their outcomes
thank you for your attention today
we look at the comprehensive interaction
detection agnostic as a fusion partner
for optimal identification of rare
genomic event using mm ecology 500
the ability to detect mobile fusion
truly matters well looking here into the
data from a study from Memorial
sloan-kettering that had looked into
their experience with comprehensive
genomic profiling on 10,000 patients
what they found is that 35% of all
fusions identified are kinase gene like
elk and tract red ruslan amongst others
us those 19 percent of Canada's fusion
involved in novel partner gene so it's
being able to detect all the fusion
partners is truly important as they use
an epoch on base chemistry this nineteen
percent of mobile fusion would have been
entirely missed it is important in the
assay selection to ensure that it can
comprehensively detect fusion detection
agnostic of the fusion partner
today we will talk about the latest
addition to alumina oncology portfolio
the truesight oncology 500 it enables
detection of DNA and RNA for
comprehensive filmic profiling
first item ecology 500 can detect immuno
oncology biomarkers such as
microsatellite instability and tumor
mutational burden which is highly
confident results it can save time money
and sample true consolidation into a
single essay and it addresses the need
of oncology today and tomorrow
so let's look into the eminent of
oncology biomarkers starting with tumor
additional burden humor cell with high
tumor mutational burden may have a high
end to ten mode which in turn can lead
to increase response even though therapy
drugs so not every tumor response
immunotherapy but high tumor mutational
burden has been linked to better
responses therefore the interest and in
querying every tumor cell or tumor cells
per tumor mutational burden load
this is emerging biomarker and the NCCN
guidelines which definitely gonna buy
interesting pathology labs now the
goaltender forum additional burden
scoring is whole exome sequencing
tumor-normal so in this slide here you
see how true that oncology 500 compares
the gold standard using 108 FFPE tissue
sample across different tumor types what
you see here is a concordance between
both si of over 93% more importantly
it's looking into the accuracy of tumor
mutational burden especially as we look
into low term additional burden scar so
the color called threshold has been
suggested today is around 10 mutation
per megabase and the accuracy and and
determine the appropriate at TMP is
definitely a little bit more challenging
as we're getting into lower scores so
what you find here on the right side of
this slide is the performance of truth
an oncology 500 and the overall
agreement with whole exome sequencing
tumor normal at the 10 mutation per
megabase threshold and we can see is
that 95.4% overall agreement as in film
so we're definitely quite happy with the
performance of true site oncology 500
especially as it compares to other
commercial essays as a surrogate to the
gold standard which is all exome
sequencing
another biomarker that is relevant in
the middle oncology is microsatellite
instability detection traditional method
is to use a PCR si for MSI detection
what we did here is comparing the
accuracy and concordance between PCRs
neighbors with mm ecology 500 and it has
shown 98% accuracy using FFPE samples
what you see here is that mm ecology 500
compares is basically looking into 130
Omo polymer Indian tronic regions so a
lot more real estate is actually queried
versus what a PCR would do the
concordance still being very high with
traditional methods but it leads us to
believe that maybe querying
additional regions of the genome using
next-generation sequencing can be
relevant especially for tumor types
outside of colorectal cancer which has
been traditionally queried using MSI PCR
essays
true southern ecology 500 allows us to
achieve highly confident results let's
look into a few aspects that makes its
performance unique so it is highly
tolerant to sample degradation which is
very relevant when we're starting with
FFPE samples what you see here is our
habit capture base as they can generate
highly yield even from highly degraded
samples so in in Delta CQ samples over
five so highly degraded we've seen a
number of them still happy for having
very decent coverage to be able to get
meaningful results which we cite
oncology 500 this is especially relevant
as we comparing amplicon based
methodology versus hybrid capture what
we know is that in pecan based
methodology would potentially require
all the way up to four times larger
fragments to be able to have enough
enough space to have farmers bind on
either side of the region of interest so
as we're looking at oncology to query
some ffz samples that I highly degraded
the ability of hybrid capture
methodology and entry site oncology
fabric more specifically to query
degraded sample is very meaningful we're
seeing some of the performance for small
variant detection looking into variant
allele frequency of five percent
and lower so what you can see here for
four different variant sites is that the
variant allele frequency can be found
with a quick reproduce ability among
even even a lower spectrum of the AF
request sample
more importantly for the topic of this
webinar here is the accuracy for fusion
detection so habitat capture chemistry
and and starting from are any more
specifically definitely provides a more
comprehensive view into fusion detection
agnostic of the fusion partner so how
does it work the probes are basically
pulling down the gene of interest
whether it's in track 1 2 or 3 and it's
sequencing either through the
breakpoints identifying the diffusion
gene partner or identifying each gene on
either side of the breakpoint and then
by automatically associate them together
so both known n novel fusions partners
can be identified using habit capture
capture chemistry giving us the
reassurance that for instance across the
61 different fusion partners of interact
all of them can be accurately and
comprehensively detected
where is an example just to illustrate a
little bit a little bit more to the
point and the difference in chemistry
using an implicant base it would
basically require having a primer to
bind on either side of the breakpoint
there for only being feasible if we know
what the partner gene is so what you see
here is an example within track 386 of
course being being one of the most
common fusion partner it is it is likely
to be accurately detected using an
African base I say but some of those
shoes and partners that may be less
common would require having having a
primer to be able to detect them
accurately for enrichment based
technology or have it captured this is
this is not necessary since the gene is
fold and it will sequence either through
the breakpoint and being able to
identify that fusion partner
there is a quick comparison between
different assays that you will find on
the market today
again looking into the plus and minuses
of different chemistry's so if you look
into the ability to detect and track 1 2
& 3 fusions
as well as the resistance mutation from
the DNA portion we look here into
certain African Bray's methodology like
the alkaline portfolio of the 1v2
that have in track 1 and 3 but but
missing in track 2 you can see that the
V 3 and the alkaline focus are actually
capturing in track 2 but the portfolio
is based on amplicon detection therefore
it it when we're looking into the
potential 61 fusion partners that we
know of today within track it would be
something very challenging to be able to
capture comprehensively so we know that
some of those divisions partners are
very likely missed in this case Archer
shoes and flex and track panel is using
RNAi detection and an amplicon method
they do have a proprietary chemistry and
henslin that provides them with an
ability to detect novel fusion as well
which is interesting but in this case
here the resistance mutation would need
to be picked up from a DNA si which is
which is not part of the solution
suicidal ecology 500 is the is the only
assay here able to detect
comprehensively agnostic of the fusion
partner and track 1 2 & 3 as well as the
four Wizards mutations that are on label
with Erica kinam and in track inhibitor
so to bring another example here looking
into a commercially available amplicon
base si out of the 61 choosen partners
that we know today only 24 of them can
be accurately can't
detective ideas and work on those si it
means that 60% of interactions are
actually missed so definitely the
advantage of going with a comprehensive
interactive user detection tool like mm
ecology 500 it is very important to be
able to capture every interaction
restaurant quality 500 enables a
consolidation of testing in a single
essay setting time money and sample so
it can detect single nucleotide variants
insertion deletion in the next few
months it will also be able to detect
compy number variation of course you can
detect fusion splice variants as well as
the immuno oncology biomarker microsites
ability and to mutational burden and all
those targets are within a single si
the contents of trazodone ecology 500
includes what is found in foundation 1
and EMS K in fact as well as truesight
tumor 174 from Illumina as well so it
does query 523 genes across DNA and RNA
those things are relevant for multiple
types of cancer you can see it on the
rights here across long melanoma
colorectal and and much more it does
include the two pen cancer biomarkers
are relevant today so it is in track one
two and three as well as microsatellite
instability as well as the immuno
oncology biomarker team additional
burden all this information is back into
a single I say that makes it widely
comprehensive
mm ecology 500 work flow goes from ffu
specimen requiring 5 FS these slides
only across sample preparation with
extraction of DNA and RNA into the
library preparation that is either
manual or can be automated and then on
to sequencing on the Lexy quad form or
the next CTX on in the research mode as
well as shortly to be available on the
Novus seek as well the secondary
analysis is done using proprietary
algorithms from Illumina that confer a
better unmatched accuracy for a 48 mm
additional burden scoring as well as
removal of artifact in SMV being able to
provide a clean and accurate variant
calling from our secondary analysis the
tertiary analysis can be done using a
third party platform such as P and D X
which is our recommended partner for
interpretation
the truth on ecology 500 also addresses
the need of oncology today and tomorrow
it includes unique molecular identifiers
that are of course helping with the
accuracy and snv's as well as the
akhirah see and team additional burden
scoring but it is also enabling a
development roadmap on liquid biopsy for
true sight oncology 500 but you can see
here some of our early data looking into
tumor mutational burden from blood which
is an exciting novel applications that
is under development at Illumina
so to summarize mm ecology 500 is a
comprehensive fusion detection with this
ability to detect choose an agnostic of
the fusion partner but it is a lot more
than that it can detect in oncology
biomarkers such as MSI into mutational
burden it provides highly confident
results for highly degraded samples as
well as with a low variant allele
frequency it helps with consolidation of
testing to be able to optimize tissue
preservation say they time money and
simple to performing a number of
different queries in a single essay and
it is addressing the needs of oncology
today as well as tomorrow especially
looking into the future with tumor
additional burden to that oncology 500
is is the backbone of two component
diagnostic agreements that we have one
with looks oncology la lily and the
other one with bristol-myers Squibb to
be able to provide a road towards an IBD
combining diagnostic in the future
like to thank you for your attention and
would invite you to visit the alumina
website for more information on
truesight oncology 500
thank you
thank you doctor Feb oh and miss
champagne for your informative
presentations I would also like to thank
Illumina for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 27 2019 and as a final
reminder our speakers will follow up
with any questions you've submitted via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we will see you next time
bye